welcome back to GameSpot's coverage of
e3 2014 this is gamespot you know the
deal do that [ __ ] do that [ __ ] if you
guys that camera do that [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] is due out of here I'll do it do
that yeah dude [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you need
to go to toilet do like [ __ ] right ok
yeah a bunch of stuff that we talked
about was on was shown some stuff I
think we kind of got everything except
for the fitness stuff but yeah let's we
got half an hour let's let's chew some
of this air shape up a shape up before
we ship out and do it ok first one out
far cry 4 they started with the first
ever game player far cry 4 at peter
brown yeah what did you think of what we
saw there I mean what's play to see I
mean did the gameplay was more of a
cinematic wasn't it yeah yeah I wouldn't
really call that gameplay I mean okay
they set up a thing this guy's sort of
deranged right he's really demanding
he's insane he's got this sort of like
all-encompassing power over these guys
and seemingly infinite wealth and I
don't really know what to make him that
necessarily we saw that the passports
tuft on my dish out back too far cry 2
where I used your passport is that the
menu stuff I mean I'm curious like how
you're supposed to be involved with with
his motives who are you like he knows
who you are and then takes the selfie
and and that stuff but what like what
exactly is your relationship to him and
that he seems to be national of whatever
country this is where is when the selfie
moment came up you looked like you were
straight-up Caucasian dude yeah yeah
although who knows because everyone
thought he was a Caucasian guy in the
rendering that's true and we really
would only see you know yourself from
one angle he stops the hell out of this
guy pretty bad that did this very much
felt like the when the reveal of vows
and when they showed off our country did
you guys read did you enjoy this
character to the same level as Vaz I
don't
joy I reveled it is really the right
word I mean but it gets it gets the
point across right like we we know that
this guy's like totally evil down to the
core and awful and gross and black
hearted and all of those things and
well-acted yeah I think he could be a
great villain yeah he could he could be
a great Ellen did it not feel hackneyed
at all or did it actually feel like a
genuine coming over the holidays great
trousers and I was the back in the
acting cells it you know like the setup
is pretty like you know he's gonna sell
he's gonna he's gonna stab the dude
right we're sitting here for like 30
seconds knowing just wondering when the
other shoe is gonna drop yeah you know
when he's going through like I said stop
not shoot that whole that whole bit I
wonder if he knows that you won't kill
him by the fact that he hands you that
pocket knife yeah yeah like you're right
it's the motivations of why your
character is there you know usually the
chief antagonist to somebody you
eventually get rained killing and maybe
I was not the case in Far Cry 3 as it
happens but yeah but maybe more
questions answers from the way they
showed this it seems to me at least to
be more of a mystery as to who the
identity of the main character is like
yeah I might be wrong like they might
give you that thing whether you know
there's a five minute trailer about his
youth coming in two days but when far
cry 3 was announced it was very much
like here's here's this guy here's his
gang and he stuck on this mysterious
island whereas this seems to be more
what's the deal with this guy like his
it seems they might spend more time
explaining the villain and they do the
protagonist yeah and maybe finding out
about the protagonist is part of the
story as it unravels as the game
progresses I'm kind of curious though is
this going to be another sort of white
man's burden story now you see what our
own character is like it's like while he
seems pretty pretty white Jim yeah but
again honestly their brows look very
similar he says I'd recognize those eyes
anywhere how do we know he's not my son
he could be I more like a brother or
something
it totally be related I don't know that
it's fair to jump to those conclusions
just yet cool so I got see I more and
more questions about far cry 4 and yeah
they didn't show much in the way
gameplay which is perhaps a bit of a
disappointment but lots of they like the
fire and stuff in Far Cry 2 that you
know there's lots of touchstones here
for like the way you know even red caps
on due to her bad guys you know straight
out of that kind of thing we all know
how it's going to play like I've
actually I'm kind of happy we saw it
like this and that we far cry 3 2 mu is
as much about the world is was anything
else and this is a glimpse at the actual
word like you don't need to show me him
trying to skin a few animals to get a
better wallet yeah yeah like it's it
seems like a fun decent world and I am I
am very much excited to play when it
comes out cool that was far cry 4 so
they started off the show and afterwards
the next thing the one thing I'll say
about this conference is man they went
tonally they just [ __ ] they went so
many crazy driver yeah but after you
know just killing innocent civilians far
cry 4 we got just dance now and the
phone app version of just dance what did
you guys think about this and Alberta's
wonderful award winning dancing skills I
just like the song happy yeah like it
always makes me happy it also you might
see it's like I feel so happy here's my
real question is how does it determine
who the winner is does the gate how can
the game possibly know who is the best
dancer its variants of all those people
it's very simple it's not about dancing
it's about shaking your phone like you
know activating the gyro sensor at the
right time for the beat the whole
dancing part is irrelevant so yeah sure
you can get into it but honestly like
look at this I don't think that selling
this as a skill-based competitive thing
for thousands of people is gonna catch
on it just doesn't seem like it yeah but
just dance has never been about
technical precision Oh more actual God's
sake mardel bit about the game it just
does its response is way more fun than
done central I just dance is definitely
the best dancing day because the moves
have I mean look at these that the moves
a silly you dance hundreds always been
like oh here's some serious moves and
then I do
and even the way like the idiot the
characters on screen danza they actually
do a really good job of like making them
into these like pantomime figures and
one that's why it's fine you come back
on a Friday night and you've had a few
its foreign languages you know you can
kind of thing like I especially stands
this is fun game Dallas Andrews always
been way too serious sounds like well I
want to do when I'm fall down drunk
exactly I got placed just then get back
to the hotel you don't you don't need
this feature to dance along to just
dance if you really do just want to look
at it and notice that's Pleasant being
called a spade a spade you want to dance
you don't really need video game no you
don't know but if the hook is the music
video thing right yeah and you're gonna
be in the room anyway screw your phone
thrown out the window just dance anyway
like the competitive part of that
doesn't really apply them but maybe this
is a thing we're like everyone has a
phone you got a couple of people over
it's like a really what's the interface
between the television on the game
actually how does that work I guess that
coming through a different console I
thought it's just like the wii version
of the game but you can okay connect
your phone but the thing is right like
so that maybe that's it everyone can
pick like maybe this is a way of having
like instead of having connect only you
has four people now you can get all get
all your buddies over yeah everyone wake
up a phone and they know what you know
the go hold the phone in your hand yeah
whereas he was like oh pick up the other
controller even you wouldn't connect is
it oh yeah did you notice you know that
he had a strap on his phone a restaurant
honor yeah it is strapped pastor says I
with his phone yeah alright his wrist
right do you imagine me people like ye
came out are you saying the wii remotes
are gonna come back you're gonna get
like those lick silicon condoms for our
new phones as well if you're drunk at
4am me I'm dancing to the music like
really hard do you honestly any hard
really hard with your economy strong
yeah yeah yeah the internet right next
up after the the wonderful joy of
dancing and Pharrell Williams that we
had with just dance we went to the
somber and bleak and post-apocalyptic
world of the division ah ok so this is a
tone trailer I guess it's not in game or
anything like that that Kevin what did I
think about what we saw here I'm still
really looking forward to the division
and part of it is the
like Ubisoft does this tonal thing in a
lot of the games its the Tom Clancy
thing but it crosses over into other
places to where it's like super serious
and it's that near future technology
where you know technology really doesn't
work like that but you kind of want it
to work like that and it's the kind of
technology you see on TV what it's like
I can zoom in really far and
everything's really clear you're not fit
slated like and I don't know this like
really this sort of reminded me I'm kind
of looking back on like the Dead Island
trailer yes like this reminds me a
little bit of that in toilets got a
child dying yeah it's like it's trying
to capture this tone of like this is
this awful world that you've been put
into and and you know it might be a
little bit of a cliche like the terrible
world with the Sauber narration over top
and and all that kind of stuff but I
like the idea that they were almost like
painting the world as if this isn't just
a construct of a world that we made for
this game like everything in this world
from like the bins where they are to
like why that that glass is broken on
that window happened because of
something to you adorable right you know
and I really like that and plus I have a
weakness for games with snow anyway ok
idea I can remember a time when it's
like oh it's like urban snow and it gets
really bloody and like maybe I'm off yet
sometimes you need to answer my snow
just blood yeah it gets yeah like this
this is exciting i like that contrast
between the bright blood and the white
snow access that's pretty in a rant all
right what do you thinking argued urban
snow yeah it's got herb and snow on his
shoes yo man can I have the rest of that
Urban's yeah I hate all of you yeah
instead of far too much yeah what martin
gaston what do you think I'm not resolve
I think this is a great great great
great trailer yeah it's a little bit too
grim for my taste that's a bit like the
bit of the start with the you know kids
dying I've zabila bit a bit grim and
that kind of I don't know i'll be happy
when the game comes out and importers
them any of that in it it was anything
like dead island no no make the final
game and i can just play it enjoy it I
that was a bit grim but beautiful
trailer and I like the the idea that
what these folks are doing is some sort
of novel and or like yeah I like the
good guy idea of this and it's not just
that you are a part of some military
group that is trying to overthrow a
government or you know like it's it
seems pretty like down to earth yeah I
like but I like playing as a just a
straight-up hero a genuine just a guy
wanted to be better than it is yeah yeah
and then the skies of flame drawers we
did actually see the flame drawers and
in the previous game play as well
Ricardo's yeah kara door is open and
close that is that is the division all
right let's get out of there after the
somber post-apocalyptic child murder
simulating of that we went to the crew
whoo Miami to LA via San Francisco seems
like a bit of a weird weighted fair
enough okay so we saw this I guess
time-lapse footage of this sick car
driving whole way there with what I like
the most about this is the dirt vignette
around the edge of the screen Martin
yeah like so it looks good every racing
game now is doing the connected join a
gang yeah kind of thing like that pitch
out anything works because every game
does it you can't really sell your game
on that basis because every game doesn't
we spoke about this the drive club on
the lobby last week whereas at least the
crew has this very open like this this
is impressive like look at the diversity
in the amount of in the scenery you're
driving past that is of interest to me
really I'd really need see how it
handles like all racing games are made
or unmade by how well they handle right
so that's very much open
that's what I need to find out so I need
to go and play it and find the how bird
um it looks good like this this is a
really nice trailer to show off what
they were trying to do with the game so
yeah it was very much just like a
driving simulator I'm not releasing any
racing happening here I said I presume
that there will be crew vs crew races
but they're basically showing that this
is a driving game and you can go to
different places yeah I'm wondering how
are great but wonder how much of the
onus is on being with your for other
your three other friends or is it
burning part I style where it's actually
more about the difference you know race
types that are spread across their mouth
sure I mean yeah what are the one
conditions Kevin what are you thinking
about the crew I mean last year they
really they really showed more about
what what the game itself is going to be
like I mean in this case the whole the
whole trailer ends with like where will
fill your crew go so to me it's really
all about the scope they're trying to
really sell the scope although I will
say I have a little pet peeve with the
crew when they talk about it when they
call it an MMO I sort of cringe a little
bit because it does not like as much as
you want to use the word MMO to describe
anything nowadays it's multiplayer has a
lot of people playing at one time it
does not have the typical components of
an MMO yeah so but other than that I you
know again it does come out how well it
drives right but I think if they pull it
off it sounds like it it could be great
you know if it drives well a lot to do
cool and that was the crew that's the
first half of our breakdown of the
ubisoft e3 2014 conference we also got
to talk about Assassin's Creed unity
shape up volume parts and of course
rainbow six which even move it is as
usual dropping up the bomb right at
there at the end and so stay with us
we'll be back in 30 seconds after a
message from our sponsors hello welcome
back to game sports continuing coverage
of e3 2013 when of 2014 sorry I'm a
little bit frazzled we have to give a
shout-out to marry cash for this
wonderful graphic behind us can you
remember that is that a thumbnail Larry
you get back get back to work we got a
bunch more movie soft games to talk
about it let's jump straight into I
guess from a gameplay perspective the
biggest reveal of
the conference Assassin's Creed unity
Kevin final words what's ya thinking
about what you saw here I was very happy
with what I saw here actually in part
because it Microsoft earlier we saw the
big rambunctious 4 player co-op uh you
know stuff that apparently you're going
to be doing in unity where is this
really addressed my biggest worry about
unity at this stage which is is it is it
has it lost the idea of being an
assassin yeah so here it actually felt
it actually like it brought back a
little bit of that Assassin's Creed one
feeling for me it's interesting the
parkour is definitely faster yeah seems
than anything I've ever remembered
seeing you see us we see it right here
is he kind of descends Dana's building
yeah like he's he's just really moving
but the speed at which he's pulling this
stuff off but that's needed right
because in past Assassin's Creed's if
you were up there yeah the way to get
down because I'm gonna jump in some hey
you know at least if you can like
scramble down things like this to
actually gives you more sense of
traversal in a way of the series's yeah
blackton it actually really looks neat
though and I'm so I'm glad that they
focused on this single player aspect and
that at the end it really does come down
to you know just getting the
assassination done and then getting out
of there but there were two other things
that I really took white one is this
looks like a cover system a real cover
system yeah true you know so I'm
guessing that this is press button to
cover it's also an it is also notably
better than the gameplay we saw in the
microsoft conference this morning honest
I felt that way they did ya do you think
that as well oh I mean I think it's yes
it's more robust I mean it's gotta
create a variety in terms of what you're
gonna be able to do but none that I even
just technically in the visual Tecna
graphically I don't know that that
opening shot of the crowd seemed to be a
lot well to be frank when I was looking
at that crowd I saw a whole lot of
popping and jerky animation oh really
yeah oh yeah no to me that that kind of
stood out of it yeah it's impressive the
number of people that they had on screen
and I'm not just saying I don't want to
diminish that that is a big challenge in
and of itself but I definitely notice
some things and I think when that most
things pop out it kind of takes away
from my not immersion but my belief
and what I'm looking at yeah yeah kinda
miss bugs yeah venomous bugs yeah yeah
we're back in it's a feature back in
it's a picture in a bit of locusts I
guess here as well you can see the UI
kind of pops up all of these objectives
are in the map perhaps this is a turn
ative or an addition to a and a mini map
or a larger map data which is that's
much needed because to get that sense of
like oh is this objective close to me
now or is it really far away something
when you've got a really small map and
just tons of stuff do it there you kind
of get I get a bit lost or I have got a
bit lost in Assassin's Creed this scene
is this leans a bit much for me into the
showing a lot of you know you I
exposition you know really making that
animus whole thing kind of front and
center not letting you live in the world
but this area here I almost hated when
they pop it to this view because you
just want to watch the game play yeah it
was it was a bad timing too because just
when it looked like this is really
impressive the amount than the number of
people there yeah dude get murdered over
here people are gonna killed all over
the place this Cajun That's Life I guess
but is it it's kind of a bit of a feels
like it's a bit too much going like
these people just buying the groceries
and he was getting started death and the
other side the other thumb attic
connection between this and what we saw
earlier on the xbox one and microsoft
conference was that the at the end when
they pulled off the assassination they
didn't actually kill the individual
themselves they left them for the crowd
to finish all right Martin do you think
that might be that's like a theme
perhaps I think that would be good I
think you know one of the things that
Ezio was always his like talking to the
the purse he's about to kill and they
have the back back and forth is the risk
we are teton patch a thing great lad
real bad I'd liked the idea of having
some sort of central theme that repeats
with each main victim i guess but i also
think both of these things that both of
the demos we've seen have been in the
middle of the revolution now if you look
up assassin's creed suity look at three
they span these games span my quite a
considerable period of time yeah so the
bits we're seeing might just be set in
the middle of the revolution it's all
kicking off and there might be two big
chunks of the game set before and after
that aren't quite like this they're out
there I'm you know the murdering the
streets it's not quite as busy yeah this
might be for just
chunk of the game rather than oh ya
think you know what I mean there was a
part as well and right at the ends of
the gameplay where your three assassins
body turns up and then there was an also
a part where the main character here
walked into a room and it said join
quest was one of the options yeah you
think some of that multiplayer stuff
Peter might be instanced rather than
just kind of persistently happening
throughout the game that does seem to be
the case yeah I didn't notice that but
if that was a thing you saw I mean that
would then suggest that right one of the
mission markers earliest there's that
full player max said as well really
lousy at up for max race yes so it's
like I think there might be a few
mission I'm gonna guess that I'm gonna
guess that it's like watch dogs where
where you know you're kind of pulled out
of it you're put into an area with
people and then when it's done you just
kind of remain there and your version of
the world you're in that same spot that
you left but you don't necessarily begin
yeah in that same way perhaps far cry 4
would be similar than in the aspects we
don't know and that's going to keep
going through the games it's time to
shape up or ship out shape up Martin do
you might be America you have lost quite
a lot you've gotten real buff in the
past couple of months thanks as soon as
the world exactly as somebody who has
been taking care of themselves what do
you think about shape up I'd give it a
go but when the US when they had the US
vs like France competition yeah the
American guy was doing like half push it
was completely cheating you saying that
a ghost I'm and Ubisoft American PR is
cheating oh yeah okay I'm saying he is
straight up cheating he's doing like by
the end he's doing like you know tiny
feel dippy dip plane whereas the at
least the French dude is trying to get
his chest at the ground them back up
again you know like it was just he's got
a neckerchief on it's way heavier poor
guy as so this is using Kinect and I'm
assuming the word connect was never
mentioned what it's like when apparently
when harmonics were on stage at the
microsoft conference they also never
mentioned to reconnect yeah um yeah 30
word this year very dirty word I do you
think Ubisoft may be really pissed off
about
yes I don't know I'm just upset that
there's a donut because they try to make
me hungry well now what that's just not
right I also feel like looking up when
you're doing press-ups as props bad for
your neck problem I don't know I'm no
fitness it's a fun idea I just don't
know whether it makes sense to try and
combine gamer culture and physical
activity and also I think they might be
at loggerheads on this one like I I like
it I actually like it more because most
workout games really are just a
simulation of a workout that you can go
and do somewhere else I mean if you're
gonna do it why not make it why not game
am I it more and make it where somebody
who's plummeted in weight and then
picked it all back up again and then
some like I need a real reason to you
know to get the fun back into the
workout and I can see this being the
thing do you think it's repeatable is
this do you think this would be because
the problem with some of these pieces of
software is that oftentimes you maybe
you get into it for a couple of weeks
but then it becomes a bit tedious
because this is the same thing every
time yeah but that's that's true really
any workouts at this point so to me it
becomes a question of like how can i mix
this stuff like if I can make my own
workout and if I have a lot of different
exercises to put in there yeah that's
where the variety is gonna come from
okay that's that's what I would i think
this i think the dancing mode looks
really fun I just are you gonna
seriously use this for like 8 to 12
months it's a shape up for me like it
looks like a a fairly fun mini game that
I'd have a play with me like I was fine
and then I was gonna join that local
soccer team but instead i'm gonna guess
shape aw i'm a hardcore a hump left I
just I don't either dates you do it like
a novelty to me Peter you really keeping
stumm there any thoughts on shape up
I'll be honest man I actually kind of
enjoyed yeah demo yeah and I I mean who
knows what other like activities they
have the dancing won't seem really good
they can always add more songs into that
so that could be fun and I'm I don't
know that I would necessarily use it but
I think it's a great way to make it you
know exercise entertaining and like
Kevin said not remind you that you're
doing this thing that is a slog that you
don't really want to do okay fair enough
I'm after shape up after the joy of
shape up we've got the world war or the
Great War great what a great war whoo
remember this Ubisoft montpelier do and
this is valiant hearts too great
our and nice tone trailer here I guess I
guess again we were talking about
perhaps some will be hard Ruby arch
framework games coming out of this this
is what we already knew about and Martin
we were talking about it before we went
live with a conference what we were done
on this bad boy I still don't know too
much about this actual game but this
trailer I think is I mean I think it
looks I don't say appealing because the
subject matter is very very grim you
know like great war but it's a great boy
whoo I don't suck but it but it's it's
the kind of game that I'm definitely I'm
definitely gonna play this game yeah
like it is terrible it's great that
doesn't matter i'm gonna play it because
this has grabbed me like I'm definitely
definitely gonna buy and play it just
looks like something that's both I like
the artists are I think that's quite
jovial I quite happy yeah but I like
that because I think the contrast
between the art style and the reality of
the situation in which I don't think
they're not trying to express so they're
trying to show you something that's very
very thing that happened in our history
that's very very bad with an art style
that's almost quite happy and that clash
actually makes me think about the
situational more than just being shown
like pictures of it yeah um so I think
if they handle it right and the tones
right and it's not to like I don't think
it will be from looking at it as
obviously not to like gung ho like yeah
war I think it could be really really
good and there are four characters in
this as well it doesn't seem to be the
type of game that would go this way
blood Peter do you think there's any
chance of this being a co-op type game
no it's a straight-up story I mean this
is yeah it seems very narrative driven
right you would hope I would hope I mean
I don't think Ubisoft has some like hard
and fast rule now where it's like every
game must have co-op that would be a bit
ridiculous i think a cabin and what are
your thoughts on this I think it looks
beautiful and I'm sort of reminded of
the banner saga in terms of the art
style just a little bit and that in and
of itself makes me interested yeah
because I'm curious to see if it can
really
both these kinds of emotions that it's
it's trying for a first I was sort of
like yeah the a mission seem a little
jokey hmm almost when I was first
looking at it does is does that really
fit the setting but then when I saw it
sort of evolve even the little story the
trailer was telling about the the dog
and his losses really good it did it
sort of started a fake cool and then
afterwards Yves came out and showed us
off the new rainbow six cane rainbow six
siege and this looks I don't know almost
like a sort of a counter-strike meet
swat 4 type of fair at Peter what the
war were your thoughts on this I went to
first came on it didn't really strike me
as anything that was terribly exciting
or new I got to be honest with you um
I'm also they call this pre alpha
footage yes I don't believe that for a
second yeah what game in a pre alpha
state looks this complete and this tight
so I'm Jonah this is a 5v5 sort of cops
vs robberies which actually seems to be
a bit of a theme this year already um
game this is a you know the elec of
other team based multiplayer games where
the duty are setting up their barricades
and what not trying to prepare for the
incoming onslaught I guess they're
seeing as a work yeah and what were your
thoughts on this Martin you play lie to
you it's like I like I think the
reaction everyone had from this was like
our doesn't look like it's doing very
much but I think these like serious
online games are about executing on the
mechanics right this game looks look
there's a setup bit this is what people
be morning from Rainbow six for like
ever as far as I can tell they want to
set up bit to come back they want
tactics like the the terrace at the star
game at a time to like you know try and
set thing you know like yeah pull the
blinds down block the doors the SWAT
team comes down I guess the rainbow team
if we're going to stick to the cannon
and then they have their own stuff is
all that later on where they're shooting
bullets in though in the walls where the
guys are like they're putting the charge
is found to blow the floors and the
ceilings and the walls out I imagine
you've only got a couple of those per
round hmm but how great would it be if
you could just pretty much blow out any
any part of this level I mean the kind
of organizing so as you're saying yeah
like I it depends how it's executed but
the idea of having such freedom to do so
many
things in a multiplayer-focused game
what would be great like battlefield has
been trying to do this for a while it
never quite gets it right because the
things you can always blow up on don't
have that much yeah structural
importance apart from the LEvolution bit
but then that's the same thing happens
every single time you know that the
thing in the middle level falls down and
like some dust comes up and I think
that's a good start but the idea of
thing able to just like blow out any
wall in this in this house or like
bright any ceiling or something would it
could be really good do you ever worried
that I because originally counter-strike
was actually a prelate of Lee slow paced
game where be like took their time and
do you ever worry that like this sort of
like plotting tactical aspect of the
game like actually trying to work as a
team that whenever inevitably when these
games come at it ever actually happens
out there is there is no about that like
they're not know was going to
communicate like they do in this trailer
again that this is me Ubisoft's thing I
don't know who's telling them how people
play online games but they've got their
information wrong it's not like this
yeah but counter strike global offensive
I think there's been a real resurgence
of that game like if you're lonely if
you've played it recently but you but
I'm really getting back into I and I'm
going to be honest it's because they put
the gun skins in like people have but
they're really going back to it and
that's there's a lot of tactics in that
game like you and I could play
counter-strike not being any
communicable not even talking and we
would know what to do in dust I don't
know what doing dust to I think that's
how we play multiplayer games and
there's always get the maps right it's
fine cool that was rainbow 6 siege we
also just found out apparently in the
past couple of minutes that rainbow 6
patriots has been cancelled so that's
not Oh ass right next to kiss wife
but one laughter press X to start
escorting there's nothing good and final
thoughts folks Martin what you think of
it yourself what was your favorite game
out of it I really liked it my favorite
was rainbow six just thinking about what
if it's a good multiplayer game I am
well into it cool Peter Brown I'm
probably on my own but shape up great
mmm like it i know i like to go stick
with Assassin's Creed on this one sweet
yeah all right well there you go will be
soft at a bunch of games of the our
whole pan far cry 4 was mine so we don't
even have a 2-1 any of those yeah but
we'll be back yeah that was Ubisoft on
industr we'd be back with Sony they're
alive at 6pm that's an error and a half
from there we've got a 530 pre-show in
just over an hour's time so stick with
us here on gamespot com for Sashi 3 will
be back pretty soon girl would